cristian machado es una persona con
discapacidad fue detenido por la policía
salvadoreña sin causa justificada en
medio de la lucha contra las pandillas
del gobierno de najib bukele cuando él
salió me dice mamá yo no soy malo porque
me llevaron ni a pensar de eso él está
traumado todavía
no tienen miedo los militares yo le dijo
no tenga miedo él ya no quiere salir de
la tienda
dijo porque vio vustra la vida del
desde marzo 30.000 personas han sido
detenidas abogados y organizaciones
humanitarias consideran que muchas son
ilegales y arbitrarias
prácticamente la base es que quieren
justificar la detención de una persona o
son inexistentes o son de tan poco peso
que yo espero que a futuro en un juzgado
en la audiencia siguiente ya sea en la
audiencia preliminar o en la audiencia
de vista pública se vayan a dar una
cantidad masiva de absolución es el 26
de marzo se registraron 62 homicidios en
el salvador es la cifra más alta en
décadas el presidente en allí bukele
decreto del estado de emergencia y
empezó a una caza contra las pandillas
con graves de efectos colaterales están
llevando las detenciones de forma
arbitraria de muchas personas pues están
denunciando que tienen muy poca
información del estado de su familia y
también muchas de las personas detenidas
eran el sostén
familias y vemos como la violación y el
debido proceso y la detención arbitraria
genera unas violaciones también
expansivas se estima que el salvador
cuenta con 70 mil pandilleros dedicados
a la extorsión y al tráfico de drogas
pero los intentos de acabar con este
problema estructural están yendo
acompañados de vulneración a los
derechos humanos